- Let's close up this hour
with something sweet I found
on the interwebs that
you'll want to know about.
This is #What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
All right, so we look to
our men and women in blue
to step up in times of trouble,
maybe after an accident or a crime,
but a Texas police department
stepped up in a big way
when they simply came
across a woman in need.
Dialing in to share their story,
let's say hi to Officers Dustin
Kincaid and Sarah Wallace
(audience cheering)
of the Seguin Police Department.
They watch on Fox 29
KABB San Antonio at 4:00.
So hi, officers.
- Hi.
- Hi, Kelly.
- So Officer Kincaid,
I'll start with you.
So how did this story begin?
- Well, I was dispatched to a medical call
for an 87-year-old woman.
Once I made contact with her,
I found that she did not need
any kind of medical assistance,
but through my conversations with her,
I found that she was going through
a really difficult time financially.
Her refrigerator had
just recently went out.
She had either enough money
to buy a new refrigerator
or enough food for the month.
And with talking to her,
she was someone that really
helped out in the community
when she was able to,
and it really reminded me of my mom
when she was on hospice
and how the community
came together with us
to help us through that trying time
with me losing my mom.
So I told her that I was gonna help her.
I did not know how,
but I was 100% dedicated
to figuring it out,
something to help her.
- Oh my gosh, you have such a great heart.
Well, Officer Wallace,
(audience applauding)
Officer Kincaid told you
about the encounter, right?
- Yes, ma'am.
So he had briefed me on the situation,
and when I found out,
I sent an email out to
our police department.
Within about 15 minutes or so,
we had officers, dispatchers,
civilian employees
all coming in and donating money
towards the cause of trying to
get her a used refrigerator,
so that way she could store her food.
And it was awesome
because when I reached out
and started researching
on Facebook Market,
we let the seller know what was going on
and she graciously
donated the refrigerator
that we were looking at.
So we were able
(audience applauding)
to take all
- Wow.
- Of the money that we
raised for this woman
and use it towards groceries
and pantry items and everything.
And then when our community found out,
they also participated as well.
So it was incredible to see
not only our department,
but our community come together
to help a citizen in need.
- Absolutely, get it Texas.
(audience applauding)
I love it.
Well, thank y'all so much,
Officer Kincaid and Wallace,
for not only your service,
but also joining us today
and taking the time.
We really appreciate it.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Sarah] (laughs) Thank you.
- [Dustin] Thank you.
- All right,
and girl also you have
some beautiful blue eyes.
I can't let that go.
They are startling.
And that's not all,
we're inspired by your
department's act of kindness
and so is our season-long
partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show."
So they'll be using their G2 gel ink pen
to write the woman you helped out
a check for $1,000
to help her out.
(audience cheering)
- Wow, thank you so much.
- Yeah, so look at that.
Look at that moment you took
and you made something really
beautiful happen for her.
That's so amazing, thank y'all so much.